yeah i'm gonna it's like i'm asking you
stock tips i'm on big cloud uh i'm on
the site now what uh
and i could see this i mean i could just
go and find it but what what creators do
you own and what what uh which one are
you gonna be making any purchases
anytime soon what do you like
yeah definitely i own active creators so
if a creator is active and like posting
and like doing fun stuff or interesting
stuff i buy them um but really the thing
that i uh
you know like the hedge fund side of me
really likes is nft artists because for
nft artists uh even today not
theoretical um all of them set royalties
that go to their coins um and so there's
real cash flows there that are often
like totally disparate like you know
like their coins are not like correctly
priced for like how much money is gonna
actually flow to their coins um and so
i've been yeah i bought like spookies
and um
uh clout punk you know early illuminati
is like another one um and those like
just the cash flows are like above what
it was when i like you know those have
made up for what it was when i invested
in it so
uh so that's kind of like i think that's
a strategy that like just traditional
like i do like i get it um and then as
we create more cash flows going to the
coins there'll be even more um but aside
from that because i know that you know
creators who could get big are going to
have ways that cash flows go to the
coins the smaller creators who i think
are active and are like gonna do cool
anyone in particular you know
that's who you enjoy that's like the
other one
um oh there are a bunch um well so
darmesh has been crushing it he's not a
smaller creator uh but he's just been
super active he's doing a lot of stuff
yeah yeah yeah he's he's very big on the
platform um i'm trying to see like
there's like matreshka who's a woman
who's very active there and does a lot
of stuff tidgeon is this developer who
does a lot of awesome stuff um yeah it's
a dta you want to know my strategy that
that worked on big cloud at least early
on this worked pretty well i i i was
thinking about okay who do i buy do i
buy the famous people that are not on
yet there's people building scrapers to
try to figure out someone's thinking
about it or they tweeted it out and it
hasn't gotten verified yet so go front
run that i figured out there's a very
simple way to win and i said
right now with any early project i've
built a bunch of social networks and i
know anytime you build a social network
at first seventy percent of the
conversation on that social network is
about the social network this happened
with the stuff i built it happens if you
go to clubhouse eighty percent of the
rooms are just end up they will end up
talking about how great clubhouse is or
what it's gonna be or what's bad about
it they're just always talking about the
platform itself so i knew okay if people
are going to be interested in the
platform itself i invested in all of the
analysts who could who could go through
the on-chain data and report how what
prices were working you know how many
how many new users there were and all
that good stuff and so i bought all the
analysts dirt cheap and they went up
like crazy because again they were
talking about the platform in a way that
was
differentiated because the normal person
didn't know how to go analyze the
blockchain and then the other one was
basically rich active people so i
thought darmesh was just going to buy
his own coin and whale shark was just
going to buy his own coin craig clemens
was going to buy his own coin and so
it's like a company that does a share
buyback it's like oh okay this person
has the they have enough funds where
they could like dramatically move their
own coin price so all i got to do is
just buy them and wait for them to do
their buybacks and sure enough they did
and darmas even said it publicly it's
like i'm going to buy for every follower
i get i'm going to buy back my every
coin holder i get i'm going to buy back
10x of my own coin or something crazy
like that and i was like well that's a
ponzi scheme that i love that's perfect
great uh like i'll just hitch onto that
ride this guy's guaranteeing and i know
he's a man of his word he's gonna buy
he's gonna buy back his own stuff and i
could just front run that so that worked
amazingly at the beginning i don't know
if that would still work i think the
strategy of forecasting what content is
going to be popular and then investing
in the people who are producing it i
mean that's like that's like the name of
the game i think um so i think that's
pretty awesome
there was a guy who would do uh fake
designs like mock-ups like oh this is
what the client could look like yeah oh
if they added in if it's how it could
look it's just like kind of like design
porn
yeah design porn i was like oh that's
gonna work people are again it's talking
about the platform and in a
differentiated way because this guy's a
designer and he's going to just design
mockups all the time this is going to go
viral great yeah buy this no that's
genius honestly um yeah and it'll be
interesting to see how it works at scale
um especially because diamond app is
like so mainstream and i think can
actually get like some bigger people to
like join and start using it um
yeah i honestly i wonder how it's gonna
play out um by the way another fun thing
we didn't talk about is there's actually
an algorithmic feed that's like open
source now built into the blockchain so
that would probably play into your
strategy where you can look at how the
feed works and then try and figure out
what what's gonna get to the top it's
pretty hard to game i think but uh but
that's that's another like interesting
have you talked
[Music]
you